from exclusive items to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between KFC in China and the US this is
food Wars
here in China we can get KFC in three
portion sizes one piece two pieces and
six pieces in the US KFC chicken comes
in seven portion sizes these first four
are one piece a la carte
two piece with a combo that's a side a
biscuit and a drink
three piece also with a combo
and the four piece salsa with the combo
and of course we have buckets we have
three main cool buckets the snack bucket
which contains five pieces of chicken
and six wings the family bucket which
gets you an extra corn on the cob
some mashed potato and three drinks and
the super family bucket where you get
desserts and mashed potato more of both
on top of that as well and then we have
buckets where you can get an eight piece
a 12 piece
or the 16 piece now if we're going
strictly on just chicken and not Wings
the u.s's largest is 166 Point repeating
six percent bigger than China's largest
chicken portion size next we have fries
now here in China we get them in three
sizes small medium and large we got two
fry sizes in the U.S the individual
and the large let's weigh the large
fries in both countries
hahaha
I never grow tired of that here in China
our drinks come in three sizes small
medium and large American drinks come in
the following size as regular 20 ounces
and large 30 ounces but that's not all
you can also get a half gallon container
good the Jesus piece on any beverage of
your choosing
[Music]
hope you're sharing that Joe
here's everything you'll find in a KFC
in China that you won't find in the US
and we have a lot to get through here's
everything you'll find at KFC in the U.S
you won't find in China One exclusive
that we have here in China that you
cannot find in the US are wings
that's right it's tough times for the US
economy in just about every sector
earlier this year KFC laid off several
favorite menu items including Wings
Nashville hot sauce to anything
strawberry lemonade chocolate chip
cookies and pretty much popcorn chicken
they still exist in the famous bowls but
not on their own ah we still got them
here and they're available in two Styles
the crispy spicy wings and the New
Orleans grilled wings now you might be
wondering what are New Orleans wings uh
apparently KFC might have invented the
flavor and it's kind of like how
generoso's chicken is not actually from
China
New Orleans chicken is kind of just a
misnomer it's a honey baked spicy wing
with a I think a Cajun mix you as
chicken Styles one chicken style you can
get here in the US you can't get in
China is this the extra crispy that's
exactly what it sounds they fry it like
twice or with more breading I don't know
because that extra crispy crunch volume
up
foreign
in some parts of the country you can get
Kentucky grilled grilled chicken not
fried I mean fried's in the title so I
don't know what you're doing getting
grilled chicken at KFC
and for sandwiches we have a spicy
option I just wanted to talk a little
bit about our chicken recipes here so
this is the original recipe but we also
have an additional recipe called the
Golden crispy chicken now you can tell
that there's quite a bit of a difference
it is significantly more golden in that
I guess it's lighter yellow color than
the original
but there's also a very healthy
sprinkling of chili powder on top
and the batter is a lot harder and
crunchier I guess it's probably more of
a localized version of the chicken that
looks delicious that's like extra crispy
and spicy yeah I definitely want to try
that here we have our exclusive burgers
and roll we'll get to that later first
off I just want to draw your attention
to the Rattan pepper flavor
Spa chicken burger at a really tough
time trying to figure out what Spa meant
and I found actually on one advertising
poster in fine print that Spa was not an
acronym it just meant that the chicken
is Juicy and tender because this is made
of chicken breast instead of chicken
thigh which you'll remember from another
episode is the norm here in China
because Chinese people think that
chicken thigh is Juicy and tender
whereas breasts is really dry and it's
basically chalky so I guess the spa is
an attempt to get rid of that stigma by
saying ah look it's so soft and tender
like the chickens just come out of a
massage or a spa treatment if you
haven't had hot pot or had such a
flavors before this might be a really
big turn off because the taste of the
Rat and pepper is so strong the chicken
is all right you know it's tender I
can't say it's just come out of a spa
the spicy chicken sandwich
looks basically the same or for one it's
not spicy and second is actually not as
tasty as the the spa chicken I did
actually not you know what I'll take it
all back I do actually feel that the the
spa chicken is a little bit more tender
this one does feel drier the crispy
chicken sandwich
it's pretty much the same as everything
else I think they're really just adding
different condiments but the gist of it
is always lettuce
the Mayo and chicken that's it and the
bun of course and the New Orleans
chicken burger of course they're going
to put this in a burger as well if
they've gone and invented an entire
flavor category that's actually not bad
and we have one more chicken options the
old Beijing chicken roll or as listed on
their website the dragon Twister so they
called it old Beijing Style
and I Now understand that old Beijing
means that you're going to Chuck some
cucumber in there there's probably leek
in there as well there's gonna be
tiemian sauce let's give the dragon a
taste
it just tastes sweet there is a crunch
from the Cucumbers but the cucumber's
kind of gone a bit
it's kind of gone a bit sad as well now
we've got the beef burger options this
is the classic American style beef
burger
imagine this being like
the introductory course to American
flavors form someone who's never left
China they're going to be sorely
disappointed oh you can also get double
beef burgers at KFC in your classic
American style or cool no thank you or
the smoked pepper flavor
if you want to bug or go to McDonald's
go to Burger King there's also a fish
burger the Deep Sea Cod Burger which you
can get as a double as well I do have my
hopes up for this one not very high
minded but I do have some hope for this
one this is the bacon wagyu beef burger
it's a premium Burger as you can tell
because it comes in its own box which
prevents it from becoming squished into
sandwiches like these guys
no no
I don't care if it really is wagy or not
in fact it actually tastes a little bit
like the consistency of spam you can get
that as a double or a triple but just
skip it in my opinion we have one
exclusive sandwich to the US it's this
the Chicken Little which I guess is a
bite-sized chicken sandwich little
tender in here also
um hey KFC if they had one note maybe
relax in the Mayo on this are you
kidding me look at this the sauce
whatever this is like bro it is dripping
now pickles not a fan
why this over the chicken sandwich I
have no idea I mean unless you have like
a kid or a picky eater skip this we've
also got other chicken options beginning
with our Hong Kong style crispy big
chicken Sai if you've watched our other
episodes you'll know that Hong Kong
style usually is used to denote a sort
of a
sweet honey roasted flavor profile
would have been oven baked look at this
glaze that's beautiful
mmm it's sweet without being cloying
it's Savory it's incredibly meaty
there's also the secret recipe whole
chicken look at that an entire chicken
see it's about the size of my face and
I've got a pretty long face you've done
well you've done well colonel I forgive
you for the burgers heck yeah dude I
totally want one of those man just bite
right into that big leg like in that
medieval times this here is the hot and
spicy chicken with bone
and apparently it's scapular meat so
your collarbone I've never had
collarbone chicken meat so this is
definitely a first for me it tastes a
little bit like a chicken nugget but
with a bone inside and we've also got
popcorn chicken
and Nuggets you might be wondering what
these are KFC is trying to squeeze in on
the pizza business this is KFC's K Pizza
this is a chicken and mushroom K Pizza
look at that ultra thin crust well that
actually pretty good
I think I actually like this more than
Domino's pizzas and this one is very
special this is the K Pizza da panty
flavor
means big plate of chicken it's a
xinjiang dish which is usually a chicken
stew comes on a giant dish with potatoes
and bell peppers and you also get some
hand pulled noodles thrown in in fact
the original story of the big plate of
chicken supposedly was either invented
by a citronis or a hunanese immigrant
who was serving these dishes up to
truckers and they're very hearty they're
super tasty you always eat them in a
group but I'm just gonna pig out and eat
one by myself on a pizza hmm
FC this is legit good
KFC has recently added nuggets back onto
the menus to the technically
non-exclusive anymore but I'll show them
off here you can get them in 8 and 12
pieces here's the Nugget eight pieces
get in there you only nugget vision
now remember before when I said they
didn't have popcorn chicken anymore I
mean this is pretty
right it's a little bit bigger than
popcorn chickens when I said nuggets you
were probably think when I was thinking
like McNuggets right like nuggets this
being a nugget is very strange really
good though we also have chicken tenders
they come in orders of 8 12 and 16. the
crispiness in this I have to
[Music]
now to complement your chicken we have a
plethora of sauces and condiments to
offer namely sweet vinegar and sweet
chili which we couldn't find today and
the Citron pepper spicy chili powder you
can't even just dried we have a bunch of
exclusive sauces and you know what that
means
sauce time sauce talk started off the
buffalo ranch thank you nuggets let's go
yeah the KFC sauce a really good
barbecue sauce honey barbecue excuse me
[Music]
classic Ranch I don't know what the
ranch situation out there in China is
but here we're doing all right with rent
the ranch situation in America solid we
also have a honey mustard sauce a honey
sauce and a hot sauce all three today
they did not have here in China KFC has
something called the DIY kitchen and
they also have stuff from third party
vendors without further Ado let's dig in
first off we have the chicken nuggets
and the hot and spicy chicken with bone
if I was hungry and I wanted KFC
I'm gonna order KFC I'm not gonna go and
cook it myself isn't that the whole
point of take out of fast food it's
cooked for you if you're so inclined you
can also make KFC's famous egg Tarts at
home KFC is also offering
Secret Recipe Chicken fillets from a
third party vendor the whole cut sirloin
steak also from a third party KFC also
selling your pasta now they come in
mushroom and black pepper carbonara and
spag Bowl actually oh this is the spag
Bowl you've got your Bolognese you've
got various condiments yeah no to KFC
pasta no the KFC pasta no to the burgers
chicken is your lane stay in that lane
they've also got rice they come in four
flavors the original flavor chicken
Japanese style fried rice what's
Japanese about it I can't tell and this
one is the baked rice this one is the
French style roast chicken cheese baked
rice and probably the most
understandable of the offerings in the
DIY kitchen the ice cream so KFC have
partnered up with Oakley as you can tell
Oatley is just everywhere in China it's
so big KFC also has this
it's called the modern ice cream
although here in China we call it the
madir and it's got a really interesting
history this originates from a city in
Northeast China called Harbin where they
hold the ice and snow Festival if if you
know about that and basically modern
Harbin was more or less built by the
Russians
um the modern gets its name from a hotel
that was built by a Russian which also
had a bakery and sold yogurt and ice
cream so this has become an institution
especially if you go to Harbin in the
winter for the Sloan Ice Festival when
it's like minus 20 people are still
queuing up on the street to get yourself
one of these popsicles it's been a it's
been a while let's see if the ice cream
is still good to eat it does feel a
little bit soft it's like Frosty the
Snowman
once uh once Summer's set in you can
just have a peek
I'll be able to drink it soon
salvageable
what still is going strong in the menu
is the pot pie man this thing is hot I.E
I don't want to disrespect any of the
pot pie heads watching but I've never
seen anyone order this I've never seen
anyone eat this this thing is gigantic
you can't get this as a side so someone
in this country
assuming lots of people are walking into
Kentucky Fried Chicken and getting a pot
pie I don't know why you're doing this
pot pie is perfectly fine I feel like
this could totally go on the menu
if you want to fight me in the comments
go for it but I've never met a person
who gets this and eats it and uh this is
kind of my job we'll do a taste test
later as for now moving on the famous
bowl I don't think this exists outside
of America so let me go ahead and
explain it it basically is every side
plus popcorn chicken or in this case
nuggets in one thing mashed potatoes
gravy cheese corn and yeah bits of
chicken look I thought they don't like
all these things but together in one
dish it's kind of so what you're really
doing is getting a side of mashed
potatoes and gravy and sprinkling some
cheese corn and Chicken on it I don't
know people are complaining on the
internet the famous bowl is so good now
they have the mac and cheese Bowl which
is mac and cheese
with chicken on it and these are the
Nuggets remember I said before the
popcorn chicken of stone this in
isn't this popcorn chicken and these too
big to be popcorn chickens is this
nuggets to replace the popcorn chicken I
want answers
too but together they don't add anything
the only thing it's doing is being like
why get it in two containers just get it
in one Speaking of mac and cheese
exclusive sides in the US you you can
get your mac and cheese without chunks
of chicken in it just regular mac and
cheese uh our biscuits
oh so dry coleslaw
China you don't want this I mean how do
I even explain coleslaw
shredded lettuce shredded cabbage excuse
me all right I don't even know what it
is we want Mayo
and carrots and corn
like McDonald's KFC also has a late
night Street Food menu but unlike
McDonald's which only has one item the
chicken carcass KFC has four and
two different types of chicken carcass
I feel like the KFC version is maybe a
bit bonier so this is probably the
Citron version then
let's take one of these fellas out I
think preferable to the original this is
pretty interesting this actually looks
like original recipe chicken
this in fact is called the owl big
chicken carcass R is uh
is onomatopoeic and it's from the
northeastern region of China basically
it's slang for howling you know that is
gigantic and you're just you're dying to
eat it so Joe if you come to China and
you want to order this you know what you
got to do you just go up to the counter
and be like I want that
chicken got it and then they'll know
exactly what you want you can also get
fried chicken feet but we've done one
better and gotten the fried chicken feet
and fragrant bones box this is the
chicken feed obviously there's also
chicken neck there's chicken wing tip
scapula meat so all of the fiddly parts
of the chicken in one convenient box for
you to nibble on these are all of our
exclusive breakfast options okay so
first off I just want to draw your
attention to this KFC has so long Bowl
this is incredible because this is a
super popular breakfast item if you wake
up early you'll see lots of sellers sort
of with bamboo steamers about as tall as
you are it's filled with these sorts of
Little Bow the KFC xiaolong bar
oh that's even better than my
neighborhood breakfast place calling me
impressed I'm very very very smitten
with this plus they also provided a pack
of vinegar because you can't eat Bao
without vinegar next we have the kanjis
in terms of flavors we've got the
century egg and pork a staple Congee
this would be
sour pickle and chicken and over here
we've got the chicken and egg this is
the century egg
and pork and he goes I don't actually
like Century egg
it's stanky but not as stanky as the
like authentic Century egg and the
yotyao the crispy Chinese Cruller or
dough stick I mean there's so many
different names for this thing but this
is the heart of every Chinese breakfast
this goes well with soy milk you can dip
it in soy milk you can dip it in Congee
it's like a churro but not sweet
but chewy these things are always best
right out the um the wok continuing on
with our Chinese breakfast this is this
is the super cute this is something
that's called a tea egg you get these in
one or four
and if it isn't it
you're going to have some yoga
and if you're having your hotel you got
to have some country
that's a trifecta it's the Holy Trinity
of Chinese breakfast we have the crispy
chicken spring rolls with a
they've lost a bit of spring
what is I feel like one of those sausage
finger people from everything everywhere
all at once
I didn't realize we were in the uh
floppy
crispy spring roll Universe there's also
a
chicken chop an egg Chinese style roll
although really this is this is more of
a wrap and what do we have in here we've
got chicken breast it looks like
cucumber leek this is what's known as a
baltui which literally translates to
thin and crispy and it's meant to be
thin and crispy but it's more like thin
and flaccid right now I think this is
Tien sauce which is um a sweet bean
paste I have to say this the Chinese
breakfast at KFC is next level I want
all of that are you kidding me all of
that looks incredible next let's talk
about the non-chinese breakfast so we've
got our Panini offering right here we're
gonna begin with the cheese and sausage
Panini just your regular I think there's
actually ciabatta bread now we've got
the cheese sausage and egg
the cheese and chicken panini the cheese
and thick omelet Panini now this is
interesting because this is a rolled
omelette I think in Japan they would
call it a tamagoyaki here we've got the
chicken chop sick rolled omelette double
Panini these three are special we've got
them just for you they're new offerings
on the KFC menu in fact KFC has been
really good at updating as many pretty
much every month they're going to have
new stuff this is their souffle lineup
the cheese and egg souffle Panini it's
basically the same
Peggy thing but it looks like it's
worked out more in the gym it's got a
better pump next we've got the chicken
shop and egg souffle panini
I just want to do a side-by-side
comparison is it not the same thing and
I saved the fanciest of them all for
last this is the beef fillet egg souffle
oh look at that they even made it rhyme
okay it comes in its very own special
box
Okay so we've got the the fluffy souffle
and then there's mashed potato
in my panini and the beef fillet now we
have live crunch again
that was really bad I'm I'm pretty bad
at the French accent sorry we have the
smoked chicken French style croissant
bread it was basically a croissan witch
let's say Square croissant with sesame
seeds and Le Bicken and ink French style
croissant bread the bacon and egg French
style croissant bread if my accent was
terrible that is impressive the paninis
uh and we've kind of got those here and
of course if you can't get enough of the
western style breakfast you can also get
single add-on items such as an egg sunny
side up you can also get a nice juicy
sausage hash browns
or is a must this is the egg and
vegetable soup here we've got the Hong
Kong style big crispy chicken thigh rice
this section beneath is just literally
filled with rice and this is the spicy
meat sauce grilled chicken rice here are
two additional non-chicken sides that we
have
corn and wavy fries get a whole
chocolate cake to KFC
in the U.S I don't know why they don't
sell by slices I guess it's for the
whole family but whatever what can I say
about chocolate cake it's chocolate's
got frosting on it it's very good
I'm not gonna bite into it we're gonna
donate it so I don't want to screw it up
trust me it's good these are our
exclusive desserts let's begin with
KFC's best seller the Portuguese style
egg tart or just the egg tart for sure
and if you can't eat two whole egg Tarts
then you can go for the
baby egg Tarts oh look how cute they are
they're tiny KFC offers them Basque
cheesecake and this is the red bean pie
that's delicious the KFC offers an
original ice cream cone but because we
got it delivered that's the cone
and this is the ice cream ah okay I
guess that's how I'm supposed to take it
out I'm just gonna drink the ice cave
here we go this is a first
oh oh oh okay okay all right we're gonna
put it back Sundays we've got four of
them
strawberry brown sugar and bubble sauce
I I assume bubble as in bubble tea this
here is the mango grapefruit sundae new
on the menu the North American blueberry
sauce here we've also got super soft
Mochi Sundaes this is the strawberry
flavor and this is the one that I guess
is basically the milk tea version
but with mochi balls on top following on
in the footsteps of the Mochi Sunday
there's also a super soft KFC Mochi ice
cream
which comes in four flavors this one is
strawberry ah no this one's strawberry
Oreo you can also get regular strawberry
Oreo and Tarot flavor
that's actually pretty tasty drinks we
got a bunch of them here in the US
starting down here something that is new
to America a lemon lime beverage called
Starry Sierra Mist is out starry's in
and
tastes almost exactly like seven up you
also get Mountain Dew oh yeah
a personal favorite Mountain Dew sweet
lightning I think you only get it at KFC
it's like Peach Mountain Dew
I know it's not good for me man it's so
good this is supposed to be a lemonade
but
is in fact
more sweet lightning not complaining but
you also get the Colonel's lemonade and
last but not least sweet tea oh yeah
my sweet tea it she's good love all
these beverages these are all of our
exclusive drinks let's begin over here
with the most Chinese of them all
soy milk we have Budweiser the
nine fruits orange juice then you've got
your milk tea with a very cute Colonel
Sanders and a bubble tea which is just
as cute and has the little tapio
composed at the bottom too over here the
three lemon tea consisting of lemon lime
and orange it basically just lemon juice
yeah I can see why it's called three
lemon
the heart warmings three black Goji oat
drink oh if you see that if you can see
the little bits of red stuff floating in
there it's got actual goji berries
it makes me feel like a middle-aged
Chinese Auntie with curlers in my hair
but in the best way possible I feel I
don't know I feel like I'm wearing PJs I
think was the snow Top Coffee
which is basically an ice latte with a
dollop of ice cream and this
also would have looked different when it
first arrived this is called the cute
bubble milk basically it's just straight
up milk with a layer of milk foam and it
would have had a smiley face dusted in
cocoa powder oh and I forgot to mention
there's also a hot lemon drink that we
weren't able to get these are the cake
coffees K coffees come in hot or cold
varieties you can get Americano your
standard latte your oat milk latte your
Rich milk latter your coconut latte then
you can also get the vanilla latte a
hazelnut latte sea salt and macadamia
nut latte and there's also your regular
cappuccino and caramel macchiatos
let's talk cultural Perceptions in terms
of prestige KFC really is the OG they
open in 1987 before Mackie D's and back
then they would have also been seen as
sort of a window to the West this fancy
Cosmopolitan place to be seen but over
time they've really become quite
entrenched here in China and they're now
seen as a foreign fast food brand that I
would say
has a lot of Chinese characteristics for
example the kanji the breakfast menu Etc
KFC's rep in this country they're number
one they're number one with fast food
chicken we got Popeyes we got I guess we
want to put Chick-fil-A but that's more
sandwiches as far as like
fast Chicken on the bone places Wingstop
is wings and Popeyes and KFC reputation
is pretty much like you're gonna get a
decent uh piece of chicken and a lot of
sides in terms of convenience KFC has
its own delivery service but it also
uses third-party suppliers like
everybody else but unlike in the US
where KFC is very much take out focused
here in China they're more about the
dying in experience especially with the
extended family KFC is incredibly
convenient reliable I wouldn't hang out
at one or Dine there I would take it to
go one thing I should say about KFC as
much as they work on having quality
control you could tell if a KFC is good
or bad by like how dark the chicken is
when it comes out like the you know and
the one that we did today I don't think
they changed the oil
and in a while the chick was looking a
little darker than it should so that's
kind of like a thing you got to consider
convenience usually the service is
pretty quick but uh it's April 27th so
if somebody watching this happened to
get KFC from Uber or doordash on April
27th around 11 30 and your meal took
longer than you wanted
my fault uh our big order pretty much
backed everything up anyway so it's
usually convenient when you don't live
in a neighborhood where they shoot a
food Wars so in terms of adaptability
KFC as we mentioned before was the first
to offer Congee and Chinese krilla soy
milk on their breakfast menus also
unlike McDonald's which kind of played
up its foreigners a little bit KFC when
they came to the China Market had
high-level managers who actually spoke
the language and so they adapted very
quickly for example there are lots of
regional differences in terms of how
much spicy people can eat like people
over in Shanghai were complaining that
the spicy chicken was too spicy but
people over in Horn Island in central
China are complaining that it wasn't
spicy enough so they were very quick to
react and in KFC Kentucky Fried Chicken
Kentucky Kentucky to United States so
pretty much is local country tastes
um yeah they've been through the
Nashville hot thing they occasionally
bring sauces in and out but
Rivals KFC basically has none I mean
it's it's Numero Uno over 9 000 stores
doubled the market share of McDonald's
way way way far ahead in the distance
unless they sit on their Laurels they're
probably going to be cruising at number
one for a while KFC versus Popeyes I
always say KFC has in America at least
four times as many locations
yeah I think I think Popeyes tastes
better but
you know they're not I mean as far as
business is concerned KFC is not
sweating it
in China this spicy chicken burger is
19.5 Yen or 2.83 US dollars a US spicy
chicken sandwich is 6.99 or 48.10 U.N
that is a 147 price increase make it a
meal add a medium fries and a medium
Pepsi and the cost goes up to 42 Yen or
6.10 still less than the cost of a
sandwich in the U.S our U.S combo with
tax is 13.75 or
94.61 U.N that is a 125.4 percent
increase compared to China our most
expensive single menu item is the Fried
Chicken bucket and Budweiser Meal which
is 146 Yuan or 21 and it gets you eight
spicy wings eight New Orleans wings and
four Budweisers I mean I
I don't know where the other three went
honestly they must have just gotten lost
on the road or something
in the US we have two menu items costing
49.99 or
343.97 U.N that's either the 16 piece
chicken meal or the 16 piece tenders
meal both come with four large sides and
eight biscuits
unfortunately KFC doesn't share its
nutrition data with the public but what
we do know is that in 2020 yum China
which owns KFC and Pizza Hut here in
China partnered with the Chinese
nutrition Society to research and apply
best nutritional practices for the brand
KFC in the US does have nutrition info
available here are a few stats alright
if you get the Kentucky grilled chicken
drumstick it's 80 calories crisp it up a
little bit with the original recipe or
the spicy now it's 130 calories want to
make it extra crispy like this one in my
stomach
now you've increased the calories to 170
that's 112.5 percent more calories than
the Kentucky grilled get real though
it's Kentucky Fried Chicken if you want
Grilled Chicken Go dust off your George
Foreman speaking of calories what menu
items have the most if you're going with
a chicken the extra crispy a breast is
530 calories sandwich the recently
discontinued Double Down has 950
calories for reference a Big Mac has
550. and besides the fries are the top
of the list an individual has 320
calories and in the family size which
let's be honest it's for one person uh
has 840 calories I've been informed that
my fellow producer Yuli song said that
their favorite thing on the KFC menu is
in fact the pot pie what next if you
said something while I was going off
about it
peas in it what else what else is in
here what is this it kind of tastes like
chicken noodle soup
this this is just okay who is getting
this over Fried Chicken are you just
brewing me Julie
ah
I'm not being a hater hey people tune
into the show because they know Joe
keeps it real